وعلى ضوئي تصاعد التطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل توفي شاب فلسطيني
متاثرا باصابته برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه
في مدينه الخليل حسب ما اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه وبذلك يرتفع عدد الفلسطينيين
الذين قتلوا في الضفه الغربيه خلال هذا
الشهر الى 35 بينهم مدنيون وبعضهم قصار
ومسلحون واشخاص نفذوا هجمات فيما قتل في
نفس الفتره سته مدنيين اسرائيليين بينهم
قصر اضافه الى مواطن اوكرانيه وفي السياق
حمل رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد اشتياق
اسرائيل المسؤوليه الكامله والمباشر عن
التصعيد الحاصل في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
مطالبا دول العالم في مستهل لجلسه الحكومه
اليوم الى ادانه تصريحات وزراء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الداعيه لحمل السلاح ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني
يحمل مجلس الوزراء حكومه الاحتلال
المسؤوليه الكامله والمباشره عن تصعيد
عدوانها وانتهاكاتها وشرائمها اليوميه ضد
ابناء شعبنا في مخيم جنين الصامت ومدينه
القدس المحتله وجميع المدن والبلدات
والقرى والمخيمات التي تتعرض لاعتداءات
جنود الاحتلال والمستوطنين كان اخرها صباح
اليوم استشهاد الشاب نسيم ابو فوده في